before a screenwriter submits a
screenplay to an executive what are some
things that should already have done
with that script they should have
checked it for spelling that's the least
of it and for grammar and for typos and
the way to do that nobody wants to do
this but the way to do it is to print it
out there's something about looking at
on your screen that you just don't see
the errors and I heard of a technique
that I think is a good one which is you
read it backwards so that you're not
involved in the story you're just
looking at the content but certainly
much more important than that is having
given that script to many different
people and hopefully people within the
business who's whose opinion you trust
and who will tell you the truth who will
say it's ready so being ready is really
important the you know what this is
great you know I'm gonna do another
draft but this is great don't do it and
if they don't have anyone to run it by
just I said I like that printing it out
reading it backwards yeah there are I
don't think this is a great idea but if
you don't have anything else there are
contests that you can submit it to and
they'll read the script for you you pay
them to read it you don't know who those
readers are they they could be somebody
who was working at McDonald's for all
you know so but give it to a couple of
them and if you get the same kind of
response this work this didn't work then
you you might want to use that as a way
to say yes it's ready okay but try and
get it to somebody whose opinion you you
value and whose opinion you trust
you